president biden unleashes executive
action on gun control and tells a bevy
of lies in the process
republican governors fight back and the
bullying of corporate america by the
left has only just begun
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment because we do have a lot of
breaking
news today we begin however with a quick
fact you're spending
way too much money on your cell phone
bill why would you do this why would you
spend hundreds of dollars more than you
need to every year
instead why not switch over to puretalk
the way thousands of my customers
already have you get the same exact
service at half the price by switching
over
to puretalk usa that's right instead of
charging you obscene fees to pay for
their massive mainstream media campaigns
corporate campuses
retail outlets across the country pure
talk passes the savings on to you
the average family saves over 800 a year
and switching is super easy you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids right now you can get unlimited
talk text six
gigs of data that's just 30 bucks a
month if you go over on data they're not
going to charge you for it from your
cell phone
i'll pound it to 50 say ben shapiro
today you will save 50
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero
say ben shapiro a lot of phone companies
they'll tell you you need
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
you don't need unlimited data what you
need
is six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month and again if you go over they're
not going to charge you for it so what
exactly are you waiting for you can save
a lot of money simply by dialing pound
250 and saying my name
ben shapiro to get started with my
friends over at puretalk usa
already so the breaking news this
morning is that prince philip
has died he was aged in 99. so this was
not unexpected he'd been in the hospital
recently
obviously according to the uk son prince
philip
has age has died at age 99 according to
buckingham palace the duke of edinburgh
who had been married to the queen for 73
years and described her as constant
and described as her constant strength
passed away peacefully at windsor castle
this morning the royal family announced
this via tweet
the queen shared a poignant photo of
phillip as she talked of her deep sour
and a heartfelt tribute to her beloved
husband
a statement from buckingham palace said
it is with deep sorrow that her majesty
the queen has announced the death of her
beloved husband
his royal highness the prince philip
duke of edinburgh his royal highness
passed away peacefully this morning at
windsor castle further announcements
will be made in due course the royal
family joined with people around the
world and mourning his lost
the royal passed away two months and one
day short of what would have been his
100th birthday
prime minister boris johnson paid
tribute said he helped steer the royal
family and the monarchy so it remains an
institution
indisputably vital to the balance and
happiness of our national life
johnson said he was an environmentalist
and a champion of the natural world long
before it was
fashionable with his duke of edinburgh
awards
scheme he shaped and inspired the lives
of countless young people at literally
tens of thousands of
events he fostered their hopes and
encouraged their ambitions we remember
the duke for all of this and above all
for his steadfast support for her
majesty
the queen and this of course follows
his hospital stay he was taken to the
hospital february 16th after feeling
unwell
and then he had an infection and a heart
condition when he was transferred to
saint bart's hospital a couple of weeks
later
his death obviously comes hard on all of
the controversy that's been around
surrounding the royal family thanks to
prince harry
and uh and meghan markle but that
obviously has nothing to do
with his death the man is 99 it was 99
years old
he'd been struggling with ill health for
at least a couple of years
in 1942 he became first lieutenant of
the hms wallace at 21 years old he was
one of the youngest first lieutenants in
the royal navy
he married elizabeth in 1947 at
westminster abbey described for his
constant strength
after the pair met at the wedding of
princess marina of greece of denmark
and prince george duke of kent in 1934
they had four kids obviously and they
are the source of the current
royal line so that is the breaking news
as of today that is the the death of
prince philip and just to show you what
garbage place twitter is
the the tweets below the announcement of
his death are all from people
celebrating the death of a 99 year old
man who
was a lieutenant in world war ii
so yes and our modern life just getting
better and better in terms of our
morality
other news that is worth covering here
so yesterday i did an entire hour
on the shalvin trial and i pointed out
that the prosecution case
seemed to be on very very thin ice that
a lot of the prosecution witnesses
had been basically torn apart by the
defense it is worth noting here that the
prosecution did have a much better day
yesterday so this case is still very
much in doubt for people who listened to
yesterday's show and they said well
you know no sane jury could come to the
conclusion beyond a reasonable doubt
well based on the prosecution case
yesterday
a saint jury could come to the
possibility of that conclusion that does
not mean
that if it comes to the reasonable doubt
conclusion that that is wrong it also
doesn't mean that if it comes to the not
reasonable doubt conclusion that is
necessarily wrong based on the
prosecution witnesses yesterday now the
prosecution yesterday when how
prosecutions are supposed to go
namely if the prosecution puts up a
witness the defense is not
supposed to be able to promptly tear
down the witness the way that the
defense had
over the past couple of days yesterday
the
prosecution brought forth dr martin
tobin physician and pulmonary
and critical care medicine from chicago
he's presented as an expert witness on
respiratory matters
and he basically just analyzed the tape
of floyd and said he could tell simply
by looking at floyd
and measuring his his breath
and measuring his chest moving up and
down if he died of a drug overdose or if
he died
of simply being compressed by derek
chalvin
frankly i find that a little bit hard to
believe because it seems like if you can
diagnose cause of death simply by
looking
at somebody dying then you are amazing
at your job or alternatively you're
reasoning backward from a conclusion but
in either case he did exactly what he
was supposed to do he testified what the
prosecution needed him to testify which
was definitely not fentanyl it was
definitely not meth it was definitely
not the preexisting heart condition
anybody any healthy person who's put in
that position and somebody sat on them
for nine minutes would die of
essentially
loss of oxygen so he did what he was
supposed to do they also brought forward
daniel eisenschmidt a forensic
toxicologist of nms laboratories who's
involved in drug testing floyd's blood
and they also brought forth william
smock an emergency medical medical
physician and self-described police
surgeon who discussed excited delirium
and tried to rule that out
so as andrew branca who's been doing a
very good job covering this over at
legal insurrection
says today's trial proceedings looked a
lot more typical for a prosecution
presenting its case in chief
than had been the case so far in
minnesota in minnesota versus chauvin
what i mean by that is that the state
finally had a day in which its own
witnesses did not
end up doing the defense more good than
themselves
he says this is what every day of the
trial should have looked like so far
it's the prosecution presenting its case
the defense doesn't get to its case
until monday presumably so i want to
give an update on that for purposes
of those who are following the news and
the trial on a day-to-day level
all right well the big news of yesterday
was
joe biden has now announced and you knew
this was coming joe biden has now
announced
that it was time for for gun control
that he needed to issue some executive
actions on gun control now
his executive actions on gun control
many of them don't actually do anything
a lot of this is just for show as
charles cook
of national review points out a lot of
this is just kabuki theater
essentially what is being done here are
a couple of things that might have some
impact on some americans but most of
this is just a sop to the left
and it's it's basically who he so he can
say that he did something
so we begin with biden's announcement of
his gun control executive actions
because again
the way that this works in the united
states is that we elected congress to
spend ungodly sums of money in giant
omnibus packages without debating actual
provisions of law
and that's all congress is there to do
and then we elect a dictator every four
years to reverse the last dictator's
executive actions so now we have joe
biden doing this with regard to gun
control
so joe trotted out there or hobbled out
there
and proceeded to explain that gun
violence in the united states is an
international embarrassment
i do love it when presidents of the
united states talk about how the united
states is an international embarrassment
first of all i don't care what the
europeans think of us and i'm frankly
confused by anyone who does care what
the europeans think of us why would i
give a damn what the europeans think of
us
after hundreds of years of international
warfare and then saving their ass from
the soviets i really could not care less
what the french think of our gun laws in
the united states the french can stick
it
like i don't care why would i possibly
care what china
thinks of our gun violence problem china
is too busy
locking up uighur muslims in zhang jiang
and why would
like who why why would i care how about
if i judge our policy based on whether i
think the policy
does a good job of balancing risk reward
and rights how about that
the constant appeal by democratic
politicians to what the world thinks
i don't care i don't understand why you
would care
you're a member of the american
democracy if you want to live in denmark
go live in denmark if you care that much
with the what the
folks in the netherlands think you are
free to pick up and leave at any time
i don't let me explain i don't give a
i don't care but here is a joe biden
explaining that we should deeply deeply
care about what the international
community thinks of our gun violence
from listen if you want to make the case
that we ought to curb guns the least
effective case here is
yeah what do the australians think who
cares here's joe biden
trying to string together a sentence gun
violence
in this country is an epidemic nope let
me say it again
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
and it's an international embarrassment
and people clapping for that okay first
of all it's not an epidemic
you know it's an epidemic an epidemic we
just had one
we just had a giant global pandemic it
is finally coming to an end
gun violence is not an epidemic because
epidemics there are things where you
have a disease and then you pass the
disease to someone else
no matter how many acts of gun violence
are committed in the united states it
will not make me commit an act of gun
violence randomly because it was passed
to me on a bus
and that this sort of language is so
stupid it's like the cdc director today
said that racism is a public health
problem
no racism is a problem of the human
heart that has impacts in a wide variety
of areas it's not a public health
problem and gun violence is not an
epidemic
stop making comparisons between things
that are not comparable okay but it's on
the basis of stupidities like this that
he's gonna push forward a bunch of
crappy
executive actions on guns we'll get to
that in just one second
first let us talk about
the shirts that you are wearing right
now so i got to tell you when i'm off
the air
i wear a lot of t-shirts the only
t-shirt i wear i'm serious the only
t-shirts i wear
are from my friends over at cuts
clothing the sport of business means
demanding excellence from your craft and
your wardrobe
your fits need to be versatile blending
timeless style and comfort so you look
as good as you feel for that there is
cuts clothing they've taken a classic
men's fashion staple the plain tee
they've refined it
combining premium quality with a
minimalist aesthetic cuts shirts polos
hoodies crew sweatshirts they are made
for the man who works hard placeheart
never settles for less all in the sport
of business
they're built for performance in the
boardroom the bar the gym cuts clothing
keeps you sharp wherever the game may
take you take a plain tee make it tony
stark
it's the bleeding edge of fabric
technology meeting the man confident
enough to wear it
cuts clothing it is solid stuff i love
wearing my cuts t-shirts
i also have a couple polo shirts from
cuts it's amazing stuff i threw away my
other t-shirts honestly it's that good
it's not just a lifestyle it's not just
clothing
it's office leisure apparel for the
sport of business get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com shapiro honestly it's
worth it these are great shirts
that's cutsclothing.com shapiro for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing okay so
joe biden then continues along these
lines
right but but the entire point here is
that joe biden doesn't actually have as
we will see any sort of rationale for
his gun
control proposals here there's no shot
in the world they actually lower
the amount of violence using guns in the
united states they're not calibrated to
do that they are calibrated to please
the radical left
that has again a complete disconnect
with reality when it comes to the causes
of violence using guns
they believe that the way that you stop
violence using guns is by barring
obscure
sort of things that are used by some gun
owners without a lot of
connection to crime the actual way that
you stop gun violence is the same way
you stop all violence you put more cops
on the streets that's precisely the
opposite of what they want to do
so what is this really about if it's not
about curbing the amount of violence
using guns
and i i say violence using guns rather
than gun violence for a reason
there is a difference gun violence
implies the gun is responsible for the
violence which is idiotic
it's like saying a knife of violence
it's like bomb violence
no there's violence that uses these
things as instrumentalities
in any case what really is driving this
what's driving this is the american
people think that joe biden has the feel
because that's all he's there to do guys
he's the comforter in chief sure he's
pushing radical policy
but he's the comforter in chief he's
just he's the most feeling
generous emotionally deep human who's
ever
walked the planet you know who will tell
you this the joker kamala harris
president joe biden is a leader with
great will great determination
and even greater empathy he has seen the
grief
of all of those who have lost a loved
one to gun violence
it is for them for all of us
that he will never ever give
up on this fight okay you know what's
really funny about this remember when
vice president
pence used to do this kind of stuff with
trump you get out there and talk about
how trump was just the greatest human
who'd ever lived
and the entire media be like look at
this sick of him look at him over here
just massaging trump well kamala harris
does this and everybody's like she's
amazing
she's just incredible it's by the way i
don't care
about i don't care might be a theme of
today's show i don't care about how
empathetic joe biden is i don't look to
joe biden for empathy i look to him to
be president of the united states and to
fulfill his constitutional duty
if i want empathy i'll get a dog if i
want empathy
i'll go to my wife i'll go to my kids
i'll go to my friends i don't need
empathy from the president of the united
states and if you're looking for empathy
from your politicians
let me suggest that your life needs some
fulfillment in it
if the place that you get your feels is
from the politicians you support
you're creating a golden calf and then
worshiping it
the white house comms director made the
same point however biden feels
feels about this he has feelings guys
i mean sure those feelings might have
some ramifications by making tens of
millions of americans
felons for owning stuff that they
already own but um he has feelings and
that's the important thing
he's somebody throughout his entire
career in public service uh who has been
incredibly focused on
gun reform you know he worked to pass
the brady bill when he was in the senate
he worked to pass the assault weapons
ban
uh this is something he feels incredibly
powerfully about
uh and so the actions he's announcing
today um are
are the first step he would be the first
to say it's not enough
he would be the first to say this is
what they always say it's not enough
it's not enough as a substitute for
it doesn't do anything that we want it
to do right it's not just not enough it
doesn't
it's not calibrated to solve the problem
because what is the actual problem the
actual problem is that we have this
incredible rise in crime across the
united states that's been happening over
the course
of the last year emma tucker and peter
nichias over at cnn reported
just a few days ago quote the u.s saw
significant crime rise across major
cities in 2020 and it's not letting up
major american cities saw a 33 percent
increase in homicides last year
as a pandemic swept across the country
millions of people joined protests
against racial injustice and police
brutality
and the economy collapsed underway to
the pandemic a crime search that has
continued into the first quarter of this
year you may have noticed
in the description of the problems last
year they did not include police were
put under the gun
and then we're told not to police
anymore okay that would be the actual
reason not the pandemic
because it turns out that in a lot of
other areas of american life and a lot
of other areas of the country that are
not major metropolitan areas crime
actually went down
because people were staying at home okay
but
the real reason that this is happening
of course is because if you
rip on the cops all the time and then if
you try to defund the cops and there
aren't enough cops on the streets
violence goes up you may notice major
american cities saw that 33 increase in
homicides those are all democratic areas
it is difficult to name a major american
city in the united states that does not
vote democrat
okay the ones that are that are having
the major spikes and crimes are the ones
that already like
joe biden that already like his policies
many of them have the same gun control
policies
that joe biden already wants nationally
the real answer to the violence with
guns problems is the same as the
the solution to the violence problem
generally which is you need
more cops on the streets 63 of the 66
largest police jurisdictions
saw increases in at least one category
of violent crime in 2020 that includes
homicide rape robbery and aggravated
assault
according to a report produced by the
major cities chiefs co association
baltimore city baltimore county raleigh
north carolina did not report increases
in any of the violent crime categories
cnn says it's nearly impossible to
attribute any year-to-year change in
violent crime stats to any single factor
and homicides and shootings are an
intensely local phenomenon that can
spike for dozens of reasons but the
increase in homicide rates across the
country
is both historic and far-reaching as
were the pandemic in social movements
well it ain't the pandemic and pandemic
is not the rationale for why people are
murdering each other
the reason is because when you take the
cops off the streets and when you say
the cops are bad
when you have 20 million people in the
streets marching against the cops the
cops stop doing their jobs we had a bit
of this in 2014 2015 with the so-called
ferguson effect
after ferguson missouri and now we are
having this with the george floyd effect
okay that is that is what is happening
but joe biden is not interested in
solving that problem
in fact joe biden is interested in
precisely the opposite as we'll get to
in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact for dudes
you don't think about your hair a lot if
you're a fairly young guy you're in your
30s but this is when you start to lose
your hair if you're in your 30s you're
going to start losing your hair
if you are on average like most other
american men this is why you need for
hymns.com it's your one stop shop for
hair loss and wellness for men
hims is helping dudes be the best
version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and fda approved
products to help treat hair loss
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements hymns was created by
a guy who knows some men's health
conversations are easier online than in
person
there are no more awkward in-person
doctors visits or long pharmacy lines
four hymns connects you to licensed
medical professionals online and that
could save you hours
you answer a few quick questions medical
professional will review if they
determine it's right for you they can
prescribe you medication to treat hair
loss that is shipped directly to your
door
today hymns is giving you their best
offer yet if you're not happy with your
results after 90 days hymns will give
you a full refund and right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free go to forhims.com
ben that is for hims.com ben
prescription products require an online
consultation with a healthcare provider
who'll determine if a prescription is
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for full details
and important safety information
remember that is for hims.com
and go check them out right now okay so
the actual answer to the rising crime
would be more cops
you know who used to know this joe biden
joe biden was partially responsible for
that 1994 crime bill that he now derides
as having been racist
but that 1994 crime bill was
instrumental in bringing down the crime
rate in historic fashion in the united
states crime rates in the united states
soared
from essentially 1968 to 1994 and then
they started to come down
why because localities and states put
more cops on the streets and there was
greater
greater federal funding available to put
cops on the streets you know he used to
know that joe biden well now
joe biden is pushing precisely the
opposite according to msnbc
biden's new gun proposals are interested
in investing in community-based solution
not incarceration except of course for
the fact that if you want criminals off
the streets
incarceration would actually be the
solution to that particular problem
the administration will also invest in
evidence-based community violence
intervention
rather than incarceration okay well
that is not the solution okay in fact
none of this is really designed to be
the solution so what exactly are these
executive actions
according to the daily wire in a
statement the administration outlined
the following initial actions in his
attack on gun rights
one the justice department within 30
days will issue a proposed rule to help
stop the proliferation of ghost guns so
ghost guns are basically you buy a gun
kit
with the parts and then you put it
together yourself let me just express
that there is very little evidence that
ghost guns are responsible for a large
share of violence using guns in the
united states i'm unaware of any data
suggesting that ghost guns are a major
problem
in terms of criminals who are using guns
in the united states beyond that
3d printing basically makes this
completely irrelevant
3d printing which is going to become
more and more prevalent in the united
states
means that you can simply cut the parts
yourself
using a blueprint online and it is a
crackdown on the first amendment to take
that stuff
offline it's a real problem it's a first
amendment issue
if you're saying you're gonna take the
plans to build a gun offline
for do-it-yourselfers at home so is that
designed to really solve a problem
is there any evidence that taking quote
unquote ghost guns out of circulation
is number one going to be effective and
number two
is in any way supportable under the
second amendment that's a really
difficult case to make
second the justice department within 60
days will issue a proposed rule to make
clear
when a device marketed as a stabilizing
brace effectively turns a pistol into a
short-barreled rifle
subject to the requirements of the
national firearms act
okay this particular provision with
regard to stabilizing braces apparently
there are 10 to 40 million
stabilizing braces in circulation
basically a stabilizing brace
is a device that you attach to the end
of an ar
pistol and it straps to your arm right
it doesn't strap your shoulders and that
make it a rifle
joe biden said yesterday that it makes
it more deadly than rifle i
have no idea where he's getting this uh
or as deadly as as a rifle
it makes it more accurate maybe
um but really it's there to to kind of
prevent the recoil from
being as large in any case here was here
is joe biden ripping on on gun braces
is that like have we seen a wide variety
of wide spate of violent crimes using
guns
in which the the gun brace was really
the problem here is joe biden on this
particular policy
the third change we want to treat
pistols
modified with stabilizing braces with
the seriousness they deserve
a stabilizing brace hook and a pencil
essentially
makes that pistol a lot more accurate
and a mini rifle
as a result it's more lethal effectively
turning into a short-barreled rifle
okay i have a question does he have any
data to show that it's more lethal than
a normal handgun
because the lethality of the handgun is
essentially rooted in two factors how
experienced you are with the handgun and
the muzzle velocity
that's pretty much it neither of those
two things is really affected by the
stabilizing brace
per se again he's what he's doing this
is all for show
so much of this is for show according to
daily wire the portion of the statement
that mentioned the stabilizing brace is
a reference to ar and ak pistols which
have
barrels that are shorter than the
minimum 16 inches required by the
national firearms act
the statement said the pistols with an
arm brace are concealable that's
really not true because again that means
that ar pistols would be like
two feet long maybe it's concealable
like a backpack or something but
certainly not
on your body they claim that weapons
with a pistol brace will be quote
unquote subject to the requirements of
the national firearms act means gun
owners will likely be forced to pay a
tax stamp on those firearms
other things that the the executive
orders are going to do they're going to
publish
model red flag legislation for states
that means nothing
because guess what states that don't
want to pass that are not going to pass
it states that do want to pass red flag
legislation
already will have done it so a lot of
this is just
for show a lot of this is basically just
a big nothing
this is what charles cook over at
national review is pointing out
charles cook who's a real gun advocate
he said all the policy meeting biden's
missive
sits within his reiterating his call for
congress to pass legislation section
which given that there aren't enough
votes in the center for gun control
means nothing is going to happen
everything else in the release smacks of
a sideshow
ghost guns are not really a growing
problem
the proposed rule to get rid of
stabilizing braces
it's a semantic topic but it has no
connection to the murder rate
the public red flag model legislation
means nothing because states still have
to adopt it
so most of this is just designed to make
joe biden look like he cares about gun
control without actually doing anything
on gun control
i'm not sure why he thinks that's good
optics considering that he just
activated
perhaps uh the most rabid voter base in
the country against him
okay in just one second we're gonna get
some more of this and first let us talk
about your sleep quality so
you know you have to have a great
mattress you gotta have a great pillow
but
one thing that you really really have to
have fantastic sheets you don't think
about that too much but
you went down to the gas station and you
picked up that thousand thread counts
you're like it has a thousand threads
that means it's great no thread count is
not what matters in a sheet
that thing probably fits you like a tarp
instead what you need is bull and branch
bowlin branch makes the softest organic
sheets on the market they get better
with every wash
comfort is not their only standard they
only use 100 sustainable raw materials
as the first fair trade certified
manufacturer of linen you can feel as
good about your bowling brand sheets as
they feel against your skin
the signature hem sheets from bowling
branch are a bestseller for a reason
buttery soft lightweight organic cotton
and a classic satin weave for sheets
that get softer over time they're not
too hot they're not too cool they're the
perfect year-round sheets for most
sleepers
bowling branch focuses on quality over
quantity no inflated thread counts
because more isn't always better
bowling branch signature sheets they
come in seven beautiful colors in all
sizes from twin on up to california king
they're made to a higher standard
they're awesome they're so good that
again i threw out all of my other sheets
other than bowling branch i literally
cannot sleep on other sheets
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlandbranch.com get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
use promo code shapiro at checkout that
is bull and branch b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code shapiro go
check them out
right now okay so joe biden
in trotting out these particular pieces
of nonsensical executive orders he also
proceeded to just say a bunch of things
that are not true just a bunch of things
that are bizarre and not true because
this is what
joe biden does in order to promulgate
bad policy he has to tell you a bunch of
lies this is true with regard to hr one
the so-called for the people act
whenever congress names an act you can
be pretty sure it does the reverse
of what it is supposed to do when they
say four the people act what they
actually mean
is for the democrats in spite of an
attempt to enshrine
voter id into law act right i mean it's
basically a for the voter fraud act but
they'll call it for the people act
they'll do the same thing with the
so-called equality act which is designed
to restrict religious
practice rights it will same thing when
it comes to gun control joe biden will
talk about how he's not
attempting to restrict the second
amendment all he's trying to do is
restrict the second amendment
so joe biden says no amendment to the
constitution is absolute
which would come as a shock to former
slaves in the united states the 13th
amendment is pretty absolute when it bar
slavery for example
some amendments to the constitution to
be somewhat semantic here
are absolute here's joe biden saying no
amendments is absolute
which is again a a weird take
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution is absolute
you can't yell crowd you can't yell fire
in a crowded movie theater we call the
freedom of speech
from the very beginning you couldn't own
any weapon you wanted to own
from the very beginning the second
amendment existed certain people weren't
allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things we're
recommending
are contrary to the constitution okay i
would love to see
his source for restrictions on type of
firearm owned at the founding
i'm pretty sure he's going to have a
hard time finding that as far as his
argument
that the the first amendment has
restrictions fire
first of all any time a politician says
the phrase fire in a crowded theater
it's because they don't know the law and
they're a
any politician who cites this as a
source for restrictions on the first
amendment number one doesn't understand
the original case
and number two doesn't understand that
it was repealed essentially by
brandenburg versus ohio you can in fact
shout fire in a crowded theater if there
is a fire in a crowded theater
plus there is a solid case to be made
that shank
versus united states which is the fire
and crowd at theater case is bad law
okay beyond that the the that does not
answer the question
as to what restrictions are appropriate
on the second amendment simply saying
that all amendments are subject to some
restrictions does not answer whether
this particular restriction
is subject to the to the constitution
and then biden expands says your second
amendment rights aren't at stake but
this is only
the beginning and we're going to come
after more of your guns
nothing i'm about to recommend in any
way impinges on the second amendment
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake from what we're talking about
um so um yeah
um so here's the thing whenever the
democrats say we're not threatening our
first amendment rights we're not
threatening your second amendment rights
and then proceed to spell
spell out policies that do in fact
threaten your rights
they're not telling you the truth of
course this is going to be a case it's
going to go to the supreme court
these executive orders will go to the
supreme court and
if joe biden had his way he would
absolutely be passing gun control
legislation in fact he said in this
press conference
that if he could pass one thing if god
could give him control just to pass
one thing that was not an executive
order would be a massive gun
confiscation bill
he said it'd be a huge gun control bill
that's what he would pass
again all of this is rooted in lies
about guns and what gun restrictions
already on books
frequently from the left you'll hear the
lie that it's easier to obtain a gun
than to vote which is just absurd
but here is joe biden telling an overt
lie he says you know what we have to do
we have to close the gun show loophole
okay there is no such thing as a gun
show loophole again this is just a lie
that is repeated ad nauseam by the media
it is repeated by democrats there's no
gun show loophole
what there is it says in law that i can
pass a gun onto my child without having
to go to a federally licensed firearms
dealer
however if i go to a gun show and i buy
a gun from a federally licensed firearms
dealer i have to go through a background
check the same as everybody else does
gun shows are not this sort of magical
free zone where everybody just gets to
buy whatever gun they want willy-nilly
without being subjected to federal and
state regulations
but here's joe biden just saying things
that aren't true these bills
one require background checks for anyone
purchasing a gun
at a gun show or an online sale
most people don't know you walk into a
store and you buy a gun you have a
background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
what i mean that's that's just not true
you can buy whatever you want with no
background check sign me up for the next
gun show then man that sounds amazing
but um no that's actually not true other
things that are not true that joe biden
said he also
touted his failed assault weapons ban
okay there is no evidence whatsoever
that this lowered the rate
of mass shootings or the rate of crime
in the united states the number of
people who own guns in the united states
the number of guns in circulations
rather went up radically
in the aftermath of the assault weapons
bill and the gun violence rate went down
okay but here's joe biden touting a bad
piece of legislation
i know this has been a hobby horse of
mine for a long time
got it done once we should also ban
assault weapons in high capacity
magazines in this country
so that 10 years we had it done
the number of mass shootings actually
went down
okay no that's not true that's not true
there's no evidence that that is the
case that the number of mass shootings
went down in fact between the time that
it was put in place
and the time that it went out of
practice exactly the same number of mass
shootings on average happened
so that's that's not true but honestly i
don't expect joe biden to get all this
stuff right because the man can't even
speak english anymore
he's now speaking in some other language
that is not maybe that's why he's
looking for international approval maybe
they speak his language because we
certainly don't
here he was screwing up he's appointing
a new head of the uh
the atf the alcohol tobacco firearms
branch of the of the federal government
and um he screws up the name several
times in a row the bureau of alcopol
alcohol tobacco and firearms the key
agency enforcing gun laws
hasn't had a permanent director since
today i'm proud to nominate
david chipman to serve as the director
of the aft
david knows aft well he served there for
25 years
and vice president harris and i believe
he's the right person
at this moment for this important agency
i mean i hope that he knows it better
than joe biden who calls it the afd
it's actually called the atf president
biden okay
by the way we'll talk in one second
about who biden just picked
to head atf because this guy is a
radical he's a radical anti-gun activist
it's the equivalent
of donald trump appointing to head atf
wayne lapierre right the head of the nra
we'll get to this in just
one second first let us talk for one
moment about the fact that hr problems
when you're running a business they can
be
such a headache just to be nasty when
you're running a business hr issues can
absolutely kill you don't think about it
when you start a business because you
just want to do business
but then you run headlong into wrongful
termination suits or minimum wage
requirements or labor regulations
you need to comply with the law you need
somebody to handle your hr but hr
manager's salaries aren't cheap they
average 70 000 bucks a year
bambi is spelled b-a-m-b-e-e it was
created specifically for
small business you can get a dedicated
hr manager craft hr policy maintain your
compliance all for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
they're month-to-month no hidden fees
you can cancel anytime you didn't start
your business because you wanted to
spend time on hr compliance let bambi
help get your free
hr audit today head on over to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro spelled b-a-m-b-e dot com
shapiro go check them out right now and
get your hr short up bambi.com
shapiro in just a second we'll get to
joe biden's atf pick who happens to be
extremely radical
first it is that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
wire member today it is matthew wells on
twitter who's hopefully about to get a
high five
from his awesome kid in the picture
matthew's young daughter sits at their
fireplace holding the world's most elite
beverage vessel with a big smile on her
face
the caption reads at real daily wire
future conservative future astronaut
hates when i listen to ben shapiro but
would love nothing more than to be
featured hashtag leftist tears tumblr
well here it is also if she really wants
a show to hate
tune on over to michael moles it's it's
garbage trust me thanks for the picture
thanks for being a daily wire member
now it's that exciting time of the week
again our own candace owens will be live
streaming her new talk show candace
9 pm eastern 8 p.m central in tonight's
episode candace's cancel corner will
feature clay travis
sports commentator founder of outkick
sports he's the host of out kick the
coverage on fox sports radio i'll kick
the show live stream
wins and losses podcast and i heart
clay's been canceled from cnn
and espn for his upfront and interface
commentary so naturally he is the
perfect guest for candice to talk about
mlb
and the infection of sports with wokism
tune in to watch their hilarious
discussion tonight at 9pm eastern 8pm
central only on dailywire.com get 25
off a new membership with code candace
the show streams on fridays 9 pm eastern
8 pm central at daily wire you can get
the audio podcast canvas on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to your
podcast so if you need some candid zones
in your podcast feed look no further
head on over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star view if you like what you hear
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so just to show you how radical joe
biden is on gun control his new atf pick
a guy named david chipman is super
super radical according to the gun
owners of america they say they are
shocked at the brazen decision to
nominate a registered anti-gun lobbyist
to be director of the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms
and explosives the goa also expressed
opposition to biden's plans to announce
new gun control measures
on thursday according to dudley brown
president of the national association
for gun rights he noted chipman's role
as case agent for atf in the branch
davidian trial while he was based at the
waco texas field office
he says that david shipman has been on
the leading edge of atf scandals for
decades all the way back to waco
now he shows for gun confiscation with
gun control inc chipman has embraced
every harebrained gun control scheme
proposed so of course biden here has
chosen he'll fit right in with their
corrupt
administration this is obviously an
administration that is dedicated
to cracking down on the second amendment
to the extent that they can
legally meanwhile of course jen sackey
is trying to clean up the fact that joe
biden is a liar you know how bad
joe biden is this the washington post
gave him a mostly false rating
on his statements about the ability to
buy guns
at gun shows without any sort of
background check to get him mostly false
from the washington post basically you
have to be the worst liar in existence
if you're a democrat
because the way that it works if you're
a democrat and you say something that is
blatantly untrue is they call it half
true and if you're a republican and you
say something's true
something is true they call it mostly
false if you're a democrat they call
something mostly false that means it is
the falses thing that has ever been said
in the history of humanity
so he got slapped to the fact check on
this one here is jen sackey trying to
walk it back
is it the president's belief that you do
not have to undergo a background check
when you are at a gun show no it's not
his belief he believes that gun
that background checks should be
universal right he says
no background check well we know what
his position is right so let me
reiterate that which is that
gut background checks or something that
should be universal they're supported by
more than 80 percent of the public he
supported legislation
advocated for that and uh advocated
against loopholes as well so that's his
position and i appreciate you asking for
the clarification
okay that is his position but he did lie
also john sackey says don't worry this
is only the beginning now here's the
thing it isn't only the beginning
it's the end he doesn't have the votes
for massive gun control in the senate
so this is all they're gonna get again
all this is just for show
but it is interesting how joe biden
feels the necessity to constantly show
on behalf of radical causes here's jen
sackey proclaiming there will be much
more gun control to come
spoiler alert there won't president feel
that he's doing everything he can to
meet the scope of these commitments
right now
well today the administration announced
initial actions
to address gun violence there will be
more that is absolutely his commitment
and he also uh will use the power of his
presidency his voice uh his political
will
uh to advocate for uh actions in
congress
yeah well um that ain't gonna work sorry
nancy pelosi basically has a house
majority
that is like two like she needs to she
needs to
hold together her entire coalition she
uses like two votes she's in serious
trouble in the house
and in the senate no room for error so
yeah that's pretty much the end of this
meanwhile governors are saying they're
not going to put up with
biden's attacks on the second amendment
texas governor greg abbott tweeted biden
is threatening our second amendment
rights he just announced a new liberal
power grab to take away guns we're not
going to allow this in texas
it's time to get legislation making
texas a second amendment sanctuary state
passed
and to my desk for signing meanwhile
alaska governor mike dunleavy said the
same thing
he said alaska is the second amendment
sanctuary state we will be evaluating
our options
basically what does that mean that means
that the state government is not going
to work with the federal government in
effectuating these laws
i'm very much looking forward to this
honestly i want more sanctuary states
against federal predations
by various republican governments if
democrats can do this with illegal
immigration
and say that they are not going to allow
local law enforcement to work
with federal agents in rounding up
people who are criminally legal aliens
for example
well then i think it is perfectly
plausible and in fact good for states
like texas to say we are not helping atf
one iota
you're on your own you want to do this
you're gonna have to do it yourself
south dakota governor christie nome
highlighted the portion of the second
amendment
that says shall not be infringed writing
biden claims his actions won't infringe
on the second amendment that is false
placing new limits on firearm sales and
is an infringement curbing ammo
purchases
is an infringement idaho governor brad
little said the same thing
so all of these red states are now
starting to move in the direction they
should move because guess what this is
going to be the first time or the last
time
that the biden administration infringes
on core liberties in the united states
it's about time for states to stand up
on their hind legs and say we are not
going to participate
in this meanwhile just as a side note
here i think it is worthwhile noting
here that joe biden who is very very
anti-gun
uh he has a son who will not be
prosecute hunter biden has committed
pretty much every crime that joe biden
has ever put somebody in jail for or
wanted to
and yet you want to talk about like a
double system of justice in the united
states
it's not white and black thing it's a
power thing okay it is a it is a wealth
and a power thing
hunter biden would be in jail one
million times over for the activities in
which he has engaged
if the man were not the son of joe biden
but as breitbart knows joe pollock
writing president biden issued several
new executive orders and actions
thursday aimed at gun control while his
son hunter biden is accused by critics
of having violated federal law
by lying about his past drug use in the
background check for a gun the gun was
part of a domestic dispute that
reportedly involved the secret service
it later disappeared
politico had managed to obtain a copy of
the firearm transactions record and a
receipt for the gun in question
dated as of october 2018 it asked are
you an unlawful user of or addicted to
marijuana or any depressant stimulant
narcotic drug or any other controlled
substance
hunter answered no despite a long
history of drug use
and by the way speaking of hunter biden
he's still going around trotting around
to the plaudits of the media saying
that that laptop might be fake and he
has no idea where it came from meanwhile
the uk daily mail put out actual photos
from hunter biden's laptop of him with
two prostitutes on top of him
okay so i'm pretty sure that's
underbinding's laptop i'm pretty sure
that at the very least
those materials are hunter biden's
materials and i'm amused to see how the
media
are going rip roaring hard after matt
gets
because matt goetz apparently was
engaging in prostitution or allegedly
engaging in prostitution but hunter
biden
is just a sweet wayward child who is 51
years old by the way
how about this how about whoever engages
in criminal activity should go to jail
that's my standard and whoever engages
in disgusting behavior
should feel the public's wrath how about
those things
it's either both or neither okay you
don't get to pick and choose based on
who the person at issue is that is a
double standard of justice
okay meanwhile we've been talking
extensively this week
about the the pushback on corporate
america
right now the left is in control of
corporate america they've taken the
reins
they've decided they basically have free
reign to do what they want with the
corporations of the united states
and the pressure is coming from the
wokest among us
according to penniel e joseph writing
for cnn black power in the boardroom is
leading the fight
for justice they say black business
leaders efforts to stop voter
suppression in the wake of georgia's
recently enacted voting bill
illustrate the vanishing separation
between protests and politics in america
today
they also embody the work of dr martin
luther king jr over 70 black executives
led by former american express ceo ken
chennald
signed her a letter released at the end
of march that pressed corporate america
to take a stand on voting rights one of
the central moral and political issues
in the united states today
the new law and those like it are both
undemocratic and un-american and they
are wrong the memo to corporate america
the fierce urgency of now which debuted
as a full-page ad in the new york times
channels dr king's words from his april
4th 1967 river
riverside church speech criticizing the
vietnam war to uphold the sanctity of
voting rights in america
the letter outlines the way that seeming
that seeming race neutral or ostensibly
colorblind laws and policies can be
designed to have a race
specific outcomes that harm the black
community
the letters spoke for many by expressing
a blunt truth there's no middle ground
said martin luther king there are either
four more people voting or you might
want to suppress the vote sorry that is
the letter from
ken chenhold there's no middle ground
you're either four more people voting or
you want to suppress the vote
um no there is a middle ground i want
every legal
legally cast ballot to be counted that
is the middle ground
hey i don't want more people voting if
they can't legitimately vote
it's not a question of how many people
vote it's a question whether the vote is
legitimate in the first place
but the point here is that if you can
leverage on the basis of race
corporations into doing what you want
then you can shift politics
and you can shift the nature of the law
by levering leveraging these dollars
and the push is is growing stronger and
stronger and corporate america is not
standing up to it which is why of course
the right is going to have to push back
because i've been advocating at a
certain point here the writer's gonna
have to turn to these corporations and
say listen
if the left is going to push you to take
positions on controversial issues
we will push you in the opposite
direction because right now
for these corporations if they feel
pushback only from the left they're just
going to do what the left wants and
figure that the right
will just turtle the right doesn't have
to turtle
but this is the the oats that are being
that are being felt here by the by the
hardcore wing of the democratic party
are pretty extraordinary
so for example p diddy sean combs
has now issued a letter to corporate
america it says no longer can corporate
america manipulate our culture into
believing incremental progress
is acceptable action yes corporate
america now must become a tool
of p diddy by the way what is p diddy's
net worth
i believe he's worth about 900 million
dollars so clearly he has suffered in
this evil
horrible no good very bad racist country
comes specifically called out general
motors which listed his own media
company revolt
as an example of a black owned media
company it supports writing that
solidarity is insufficient
if corporations don't offer financial
help okay this is the part that's really
fun we are now just in straight
blackmail territory
right when you are when you are just
saying to corporations we are going to
call you racist and part of the problem
unless you sign me a check that's just
extortion that's just blackmail
so pd writes this letter and if
corporations came to it they deserve
what they get
to be perfectly honest with you if a
corporation has so little spine that
they cave to this sort of nonsense
they deserve to be torn down i'm not i'm
not going to stand in the way a pdn
company tearing down gm
if gm decides to cave to them okay so
here's what his letter says
if you are neutral in situations of
injustice you have chosen the side of
the oppressor that's a quote from
desmond tutu
these same feat these companies use to
stand with us in solidarity are the same
feats they used to stand on our necks
and first of all that in and of itself
is egregious language
and it's comparing the death of george
floyd a man who died to the fate of
people like p diddy who's worth 900
million
dollars when confronted by the leaders
of several black-owned media companies
says p diddy general motors listed my
network revolt
as an example of black owned media it
supports while revolt does receive
advertising revenue from gm
our relationship is not an example of
success instead revolt just like other
black owned media companies
fights for crumbs while gm makes
billions of dollars every year from the
black community
so so basically his case is that if a
black person buys
an auto from gm that money must be
reinvested with a black person
so segregation is what you're talking
about here says pd
exposing gm's historic refusal to fairly
invest in black owned media
is not an assassination of character
it's exposing the way gm and many other
advertisers have already have always
treated us
no longer can corporate america
manipulate our community into believing
that incremental progress
is acceptable action okay this is
straight up
al sharpton going to macy's and saying
i'm going to call you guys racial
profilers and racists
unless you make a donation to the
national action network this is where we
are now in american life
this is the case being made by the left
with regard to racial reparations that
you're you're racist if you don't
actually just give money
just straight checks to black people and
we have not
worked out how it's going to work yet
but we're going to simply just put that
out there
that's pd right here saying that gm is
racist unless it signs him a larger
check
says p diddy corporations like general
motors have exploited our culture
undermined our power excluded black
entrepreneurs from participating in the
value created by black consumers
in 2019 brands spent 239 billion on
advertising
less than one percent of that was
invested in black owned media companies
yeah so what i mean are they invested
is that because they hate black people
or because the most efficient
media companies reaching an audience
that gm is trying to serve
aren't black owned this whole thing is
an absurdity but again
when it comes to the left woke causes
equity is just a guys for
benefits give me what i want and if you
don't i'm gonna call you a racist
basically everything i like now on the
democratic side is infrastructure
everything i don't like is racist
alrighty we will be back here later
today with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show first you can't forget to
end your week by checking out the andrew
clavin show drew show
is every single friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so
head on over to dailywire.com this
evening at 7 pm eastern and tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowski
editing is by adam scievitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin